Це кадри одного з перших документальних фільмів про Голодомор.
У цій маловідомій українцям документалці, створеній на початку 80-х канадською діаспорою,
- свідчення тих, хто врятувався від голоду 33-го, емігрантів з України,
а також інтерв'ю із західними істориками, які вже тоді досліджували тему Голодомору.
Серед них - американець Джеймс Мейс. Саме цей випускник Гарварду пізніше доведе світу,
що голод в Україні 1933 року був актом геноциду. Він переїде до України,
де створить сім'ю і почне відкривати правду про найбільшу українську трагедію
ХХ століття самим українцям.
Що ж, головним організатором, я вважаю, був Сталін.
Утім, спершу Мейс сам не вірив, що голод 33-го був штучним.
Розповіді його гарвардського учителя, українця за походженням,
Романа Шпорлюка його не переконували. Тож, він сам вивчив українську мову
і почав шукати докази. І знайшов. Згодом його запросили очолити комісію Конгресу США,
яка мала дослідити, чи справді українців нищили голодом в Радянському Союзі.
Всі думали, ну, є комісія, ну, видадуть якусь таку брошурку, поспівчуваємо за жертвами голоду,
а ні - вийшло в результаті 4 томи, в яких свідчення очевидців Голодомору
і рапорт американського конгресу, в якому, як грім, серед ясного неба прозвучало,
що в Україні відбувся геноцид, який був спрямований проти українців як нації і України як держави.
Мейс не просто довів, що сталінський режим мав намір голодом знищити українців як націю,
але й те, що в роки, коли українці вмирали від голоду, зерно продавалося у західні країни,
які були поінформовані про трагедію через своїх дипломатів.
Для тодішньої Америки це була надто радикальна заява - до визнання Голодомору
геноцидом у конгресі США минуло аж 20 років після висновків Джеймса Мейса.
Це сталося у 2018-му, через три роки після початку війни на Донбасі.
Джеймс передбачав військову загрозу, територіальні претензії, політичні претензії,
історичні претензії Росії до України. І він вважав, що саме визнання Голодомору
актом геноциду зупинить їхні загребущі руки…
"Ваші мертві вибрали мене", - казав Мейс українцям, прагнучи далі досліджувати історію України.
Але зробити це в наукових інститутах США було складно.
Тож у 1992-му з кількома валізами він переїжджає до Києва.
Тут починає викладати у Києво-Могилянській академії.
І одного дня зустрічає письменницю Наталю Дзюбенко.
Ми не могли наговоритися. Перший тиждень ми тільки те й робили, що розмовляли.
Усе те, про що Джеймс Мейс довідався з історичних документів, Наталія знала з дитинства.
Вона з родини, яка теж постраждала під час Голодомору. У 1932-33 роках від голоду
загинули семеро дітей її діда, тобто її рідних дядьків.
У маленьку квартиру Наталі на Троєщині Джеймс перевіз усі свої книжки зі Штатів.
Якщо в людини не буде хліба і забираєш від нього картоплю, то ясно, що хтось буде голодний,
і так і було під час Голодомору…
Ідея, щоби українці щороку у роковини Голодомору запалювали свічку у вікні,
народилася саме у цій квартирі.
І раптом він побачив свічку в руках Тараса Шевченка, подивився і каже:
о, це те, що нам потрібно. Але цього тоді ніхто не сприйняв.
Коли Мейс у 2003-му році озвучив таку ідею у Верховній Раді,
комуністи кричали йому "янкі гоу хоум" - забирайся додому!
Дружина Наталя стала боятися за чоловіка-американця, коли він сам повертався додому.
Троєщина в 90-х була одним із найбільш кримінальних районів у Києві.
Він вийшов о 6 ранку за цигарками в кіоск. Я чекаю-чекаю, 15-20 хвилин...
Я захвилювалася, вийшла і бачу - там якийсь полковник. Міліція. Б'є його і кричить: крові хочу!
Буквально я встигла в той момент, коли він йому ледве не переламав хребет.
Джеймс Мейс не дожив до моменту, коли в українській столиці збудують Музей Голодомору.
На схилах Дніпра музей у вигляді свічки відкрили у 2008-му.
Працівник музею, історик Михайло Костів вже 4 роки збирає свідчення очевидців трагедії,
і чимало українців, з якими він розмовляє, розповідають про пережиту ними трагедію
вперше в житті. Каже, унікальність роботи Мейса у тому, що окрім збору двох сотень свідчень,
він написав звіт, який став підґрунтям для визнання Голодомору геноцидом у світі.
Коли ми не будемо розповідати історію геноцидів, зокрема таких як Голодомор,
то ми маємо ризик цього постійного повторення. А розкриття історії Голодомору
допомагає розкриттю теми злочинів проти людяності. Коли говорити про роботу Джеймса Мейса,
про роботу його комісії, то можна переглянути - там є дуже багато свідчень,
коли не вказувалися прізвище, ім'я та по-батькові цих людей, тому що люди навіть в Америці,
в Канаді боялися, що цей комуністичний тоталітарний режим дістане їх і там.
Це був реальний страх, реальна боязнь.
Джеймс Мейс помер у 2004-му році від хвороби. Останні місяці життя він провів,
переконуючи закордонних дипломатів, щоб ті ініціювали визнання Голодомору геноцидом у світі.
Але навіть Верховній Раді України, аби ухвалити таке рішення, знадобилося ще три роки
після його смерті і одна революція.
Поховали Джеймса Мейса, як він і хотів, у Києві. Він так і не побачив втілення акції "Запали свічку".
Українці почали робити це вже після його смерті - у четверту суботу листопада.